Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
This week's The N-ko Show has started!
It has become more humid lately.
As you can see, I have lots of hair,
so it gives me a lot of trouble when it's humid.
I hope summer will come soon.
By the way, I bought an Apple Watch recently.
It measures my workout time and sleeping time,
I can take a train just by tapping my watch,
and buy a drink at a convenience store.
The world really has become convenient.
I feel like I've become the protagonist of a sci-fi anime.
So I love it a lot.
Everyone,
please do some shopping
and blow away the humid air!
Well then, let's start this week's The N-ko Show!
Weekly Favorites!
I will share my recommendations based on my personal preference again.
This is the theme.
It's dangerous to watch late at night?
Anime with delicious-looking dishes that are sure to make you hungry!
Dishes that appear in anime look really delicious.
Some of them are dishes you can eat in the real world,
and some are unknown dishes in a fantasy world.
The various dishes will stimulate your dream and appetite.
This time, I'll introduce anime that features dishes
that especially impressed me, among the attractive "anime dishes."
Here is the first one.
DRIFTING DRAGONS.
In a world where the creature called dragons live,
a group of drakers hunt dragons and travel in the sky.
This anime depicts the story of the drakers.
Mika, the protagonist, loves eating dragon meat.
So in the anime,
various dragon dishes Mika likes are featured.
Like Dragon Tail Meat Sandwich,
and Pressed Dragon Treinne.
There are many dishes made with dragon meat,
and every single one of them looks really delicious.
It uses food ingredients in a fantasy world
to make dishes close to the real world.
Seeing that, I can somehow imagine the taste with its seasonings,
but it makes me very curious about what dragon meat tastes like.
Next, it is this anime.
BAKI.
To surpass his father, Yujiro Hanma, who is celebrated as
the strongest creature on Earth,
Baki received various training and fought against many martial artists.
This anime depicts the growth of the protagonist Baki Hanma.
There are many highlights in BAKI,
like its memorable lines and techniques.
But actually, the scenes of food are also very impressive!
What stays in my memory most
is a scene where Baki Hanma was poisoned by his opponent and was dying.
His rival and friend, Sea King Retsu,
prepared nourishing dishes to detoxify and help him recover.
The many Chinese dishes look delicious, seeing Baki eating them all at once
really stimulated my appetite.
He drank a large amount of water for dessert at the end,
it was so much that it looked tormenting.
So I don't think I can drink that,
but the Chinese dishes prepared by Sea King Retsu
are something I do want to try.
Also, there are scenes where he eats a thick piece of steak,
and enjoys a delicious breakfast.
So I personally think BAKI is an anime with a strong food element.
When dishes we're familiar with in our daily life are featured,
it's rather easy to eat them,
so it's fun to enjoy them while thinking about the anime.
This is the last one.
LAID-BACK CAMP.
This anime features some high school girls leisure camping.
Besides elements of camping,
there are various dishes they eat during camping,
which we must mention when we talk about the anime.
Many LAID-BACK CAMP fans must've tried s'mores.
I've been eating s'mores since I was little and I love it.
Because they're cooking outdoors,
utensils and food ingredients are limited,
so the Japanese girls cook various dishes
using creativity, effort, and passion.
Even if it's simple at a glance,
cooking and eating outdoors makes a dish more delicious.
This anime makes me jealous.
There's a dish in the anime I'd like to try,
and it's pasta soup.
At the simplest and coldest camping site,
I can imagine its mild flavor warming up my body and heart!
When I have time, I want to go camping
and eat some delicious dishes in a large open space too.
All dishes in the anime I introduced today
will make you starve if you watch the anime late at night,
so pay attention to when you watch them.
That's it for Weekly Favorites.
N-ko English.
In this segment, I will share how to say anime quotes in English.
This time, I'll share an anime quote you'll want to use
when you get the chance.
Well then, let's begin.
This is today's quotation.
"Catch it properly, eat it properly."
Catch it properly, eat it properly.
This is what Mika,
protagonist of DRIFTING DRAGONS, said when she fought against a dragon.
The way Mika faces dragons is summarized in this quote,
so I think many people like it.
Do practice it till you can say it anytime you want.
A little tip on pronunciation.
Put an emphasis on "properly."
Properly.
Pro-perly.
It's how you pronounce it.
When you go fishing with your friend...
If you say this when you can't catch the fish the way you want,
no doubt your friend will think that you're cool!
Please use this quote.
That's it for N-ko English.
N-ko's Q & A.
I will answer your questions again this week.
Let's start.
This is the first question.
"Is there any YouTuber you like now?"
Let me think... There is one I've liked for a while,
it's someone called Liziqi.
I think she has 15.2 million subscribers,
and she is a very popular Chinese YouTuber.
She lives in the countryside,
in a mountain that looks like old-time China.
She harvests various kinds of food from her garden,
and makes her own bedding from cotton.
She's really amazing.
Please go and have a look.
The videos are gorgeous too, and therapeutic to watch.
"What is the national anime of America?"
Let me think...
Generally speaking, it probably is TOM AND JERRY,
it's the first one that comes to mind.
Or SNOOPY. To people of my generation,
I think SPONGEBOB counts as the national anime.
"Who is the character you want to try cosplaying?"
I want to cosplay a character who wears flamboyant costumes.
But my hair is white,
so I'll choose a character who also has white hair.
I would like to cosplay INUYASHA's Sesshomaru.
"Is there any dish you like at your staff canteen?"
I order takeaway every time at Netflix,
so it isn't like at our staff canteen.
But I always have pad thai when Thai cuisine is served.
"If it's allowed,
please tell us something only Netflix employees know."
We name all our meeting rooms with names of anime.
So we talk like,
"Today's meeting will be held at DEVILMAN CRYBABY,"
or, "There are many windows in RILAKKUMA AND KAORU's room,
and it's very comfortable."
It's the daily conversation between our employees.
Thank you for your many questions today as well!
I'm still waiting for you to send me your questions!
That's it for N-ko's Q & A.
The N-ko Show! It's now time to say goodbye.
This time, I introduced many anime that will make you hungry,
so tonight, I'll make some personal effort to cook.
Until next week,
I'm going to watch the season two of LOVE, DEATH & ROBOTS!
Let's meet again next time!
See you!